[Musique]
casimir 4 à casimir on le tue seul un
petit renard enfin de grippe à quoi le
hall 1 le ciel est bleu les oiseaux
chantent il ya du soleil enfin le temps
dit ce n'est pas le moment de s'endormir
que se passe t'il une catastrophe la
forêt est en train de brûler non donc
voila c c'est le capitaine qui a fait
naufrage avec sabrina non non pire que
sa peau niasse ou inventer sa 5000e
devinettes alors l'atelier pas du tout
c'est encore pire non nous ne me dis pas
qu'il n'ya plus de saucisses de toulouse
dans l'est la non mais quelle idée
laisse moma soir j'ai vraiment eu peur
comme enfin casimir tu ne penses qu'à
manger c'est cela qui est effrayant
qu'on écoute toi je sens quand tu vas
devenir désagréable ordi moi vite ce qui
t'amène aujourd'hui n'est pas un jour
comme les autres
je sais c'est mon jour de ménage à part
ça à part ça c'est la sainte julie c'est
la fête de toutes les filles grandes ou
petites jeunes ou moins jeunes au
berceau ou grands mères la fête de
toutes les jolies qu'en mai mais c'est
une catastrophe enfin c'est bien ce que
je disais si la fed un autre joli
j'ai complètement oublié je n'ai pas de
cadeau pour elle et moines ou alors il
faut pourtant trouver une idée
rapidement et effilée au jardin
retrouver julie il faut faire quelque
chose
oui mais qu'est ce qu'on va faire ça il
faut trouver une idée pour rien c'est
court je ne sais pas
iata
à jeun qu'en cas
[Musique]
bonjour vous me surprenez je ne vous
avais pas entendu arriver je me retrouve
un peu j'ai intérêt à être bien toute la
journée
mes amis viennent me souhaiter m'a fait
alors je ne veux pas les décevoir
tiens en voilà deux qui arrivent déjà au
fond alors tu viens hippolyte
enfin il faut se lancer une fois pour
toutes je n'ose pas emile nous n'avons
pas cadeau ne pouvons pas lui dire bonne
fête julie en lui serrant la main en
passant il fallait penser avant a pour
sûr pour le cadeau maintenant c'est trop
tard
et si nous passions sans rien lui dire
donc c'est vrai elle ne pourrait pas
nous en vouloir d'avoir oublié son
cadeau puisque nous serions censés ne
rien savoir
ces lâches que tu dis là il faut limiter
ce n'est pas gentil
oui vous avez raison et mise ma timidité
me fait dire des bêtises et de plus dans
ma position ce n'est pas croyable c'est
vrai un facteur de rencontre un facteur
n'oublie pas la fête de ses amis c'est
normal enfin et oui à cause du
calendrier des postes a juste ouais mais
pourtant vous aviez oublié vous aussi
c'est moi qui avais dit que nous étions
le 8 avril jour de la sainte où je vis
oui ben je me suis réveillé un peu plus
tard aujourd'hui
alors qu'est ce que nous faisons j'en
sais rien et politologue
regarde qu'il y ait un par là le
capitaine qui coûte
nous allons observer et voir ce qu'il
fait ensuite nous ferons comme lui mais
ce n'est pas lâcher ça aussi ben oui
peut-être que ces pratiques allait bien
mais son passé
emilie hippolyte c'est bizarre ça julie
comment allez vous bonjour capitale en
un jour comme aujourd'hui ça ne peut
aller que très bientôt à bout parce que
c'est parce que quoi mais vous n'avez
pas une petite idée pour le moins vous
savez moi les idées 1 c'est pas mon
métier capitale quelque chose
excusez-moi julie au je suis content
d'eux mêmes bonjour comment ça c'est pas
ça excusez moi je croyais que j'avais
oublié de vous dire bonjour là tout à
l'heure en arrivant ça n'est rien au
revoir capitale on voit que je lis mais
qu'est ce qui lui prend pas fameuse
votre idée l'infini pour sûr ce normal
c'était une idée l'arche
non non non non non non non non non non
non reprenons ça ne va pas mais si tu
crois que c'est facile
attention 2 3 4 et 1 2 3 non mais lâchez
moi a mis à l'essai pour la cadence qui
allie mire je sens que je l'appelle
peureuse silence silence dans les rangs
1 2 3 non non c'est vraiment pas trop
sinon ça ne va pas cette idée de faire
un petit bar est pour l'a fait joli et
très mauvaise
c'était le plus léger les jeux ne semble
pas être le mot juste il avait l'air
d'un troupeau d'éléphants
voilà qui est pourtant un troupeau
d'éléphants
c'est un gros cadeau ça oui baril fait
il faut tout de même les missions et et
ça fait le facteur a raison il faut
continuer
allons-y natation mais qu'est ce que
vous faites la fête wibert lui faire les
pitres ailleurs vous gêner les clients
de mon kiosque
non non non mais on ne peut pas parce
que c'est un cadeau oui c'est une sorte
de don menacé un petit un petit bal et
un valet mais vous n'y connaissez rien
allez je vais vous faire répéter
attention à 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 plus souple 1
2 3 non non l'entente va bien mais ça ne
va pas jouer ici c'est toi qui nous fait
répéter ça ne veut plus rien dire
nous préparions une danse pour
d'affaires oui oui oui c'est vrai mais
c'est raté
il n'ya plus de surprise on avait
presque oublié la date m'enfin tout
acabit moment nous avons pensé à cette
idée
comme c'est gentil moi
et moi je suis prêt a rajouté une
promenade en barque joli cadeau un sou
consciente et a accepté mon invitation
merci capitaine et moi je me tiens à
disposition pendant une semaine pour
t'aider à tenir tant qu en ce cas moi je
lis je vous offre ma collection
le calendrier des postes vous verrez
c'est très pratique pour se souvenir des
dates d'importance quand un mois à
partir de demain je serai chez 3 à
l'ombre pour faire le ménage la lessive
et et moi la cuisine on réécoute casimir
c'est très gentil mais enfin je peux que
vous inviter tous à dîner ce soir chez
moi pour fêter la scène julie d'oublier
rien on dit c'est vrai oui faites à
toutes les jolies jambes tu attends
[Musique]